[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était tout juste après la guerre dans
un petit bal qu'avait souffert sur une
piste de misère il y en avait deux à
découvert parmi les travaille le dansait
dans ce petit bal qui
s'appelait qui s'appelait qui
s'appelait qui
s'appelait
non non je ne me souviens plus du nom du
bal perdu ce dont je me souviens c'est
de ces amoureux qui ne regardaient rien
autour d'eux il y avait tant
d'insoucience dans leurs gestes émus
alors quelle
importance le nom du B B perdu non je ne
me souviens plus du nom du bal perdu ce
dont je me souviens c'est qu'il étaient
heureux les yeux au fond des yeux et
c'était bien et c'était
bien il a buvé dans le même verre
toujours sans se quittit les yeux il
faisait la même prière d'être toujours
our toujours heureux parmi les grav il
souriait dans ce petit bal qui
s'appelait qui
s'appelait qui s'appelait qui
s'appelait
non non je ne me souviens plus du nom du
bal perdu ce dont je me souviens c'est
de ces amoureux qui ne regardaient rien
autour
d'eux il y avait tant
d'insoucience dans leurs gestes émus
alors qu'elle importa
le nom du bal perdu non je ne me
souviens plus du nom du bal perdu ce
dont je me souvient ce qu' les était
heureux les yeux au fond les yeux et
c'était bien et c'était
[Musique]
bien alors quand
l'accordéoniste s'est arrêté et le son
par
le soir est tombé dessus la piste sur
les gravas et sur ma
vie il estit redevenu tout
triste ce petit balle qui
s'appelait qui
s'appelait
non non je me souviens plus du nom du
Val perdu ce dont je me souviens c'est
de ces amoureux qui ne regardaient rien
autour d'eux il y avait tant de lumière
avec dans la rue alors la belle
affaire le nom du bal perdu non je ne me
souviens plus du nom du bal perdu ce
dont je me souviens c'est qu'on était
heureux les yeux au fond des yeux
et c'était
bien et c'était bien oh
oui c'était
[Musique]
bien